-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're hanging out
with Lil Rel Howery.
We'll see him on tour
with Tiffany Haddish.
We're about to play
"Hey, Robot." Here we go.
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
This is based
on the real board game
"Hey, Robot" that
you can play at home.
It's like
the classic game "Password,"
but your partner
is a smart speaker.
First, I will pick a card
with a word on it,
and then we'll take turns asking
a question to get the speaker
to say that word
somewhere in the answer.
Okay? If you get it right,
you get a point. Ready for this?
-Change the name of this game
to "Hey, A.I."
-Yeah, that's basically
what it is.
Okay. Ready for this?
Alexa, name the characters
in "Wizard of Oz."
-According to fandom,
the main characters
from "The Wizard of Oz"
include Dorothy Gale,
Professor Marvel,
the carriage driver,
the Wizard of Oz,
the gatekeeper,
the guard who cries,
the Scarecrow...
[ Ding! ]
Yes. Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Carriage driver?
Alexa, stop! Alexa, stop.
No one ever heard
of those other characters.
-What was the order
of that call sheet?
-I don't know.
She said the carriage driver.
I didn't know Dorothy's
last name.
What was her name?
That's a little too specific.
If you know Dorothy's last name,
you've seen "Wizard of Oz"
too many times.
Wow! The carriage driver?
Yeah. No one remembers.
Okay, here we go.
Who are you for Halloween?
Hello. I'm the carriage
driver from "Wizard..."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. That's funny.
-Alright.
You're up, bud.
Here you go.
-So, do I not show you what --
-Yeah, you can show me.
I'm playing with you. Right?
I can show the crowd, too,
if I want to, right?
-Yes.
-Okay.
Uh, you see it.
T-Rex.
-[ Sighs ]
Hey, Siri.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
It's Alexa. It's Alexa.
-Oh. Oh.
I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
I'm sorry. I really am sorry.
Okay, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Ah.
Because I wonder if they going
to say that. Ah.
-I think I got it.
-Okay, okay.
Hey, Alexa, um...
Dinosaurs in "Jurassic Park."
-Sorry, I don't know that.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. I never even
heard her say that before.
She doesn't know that there's --
[ Laughter ]
-That's not -- Alexa.
The animal characters
in "Jurassic Park."
[ Laughter ]
-From fandom.com, pteranodons
are both enemies and mounts
originating from
the Jurassic Park franchise.
-There you go.
Alright, my turn.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait.
Alright. Ready?
Alexa, who sings
"Get it on, bang a gong"?
"get it on, bang a gong"?
-According to
an Alexa Answers contributor,
"Bang a Gong, (Get It On)"
was sang
by English rock band T-Rex.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Get it on ♪
♪ Bang a gong ♪
♪ Get it on ♪
♪♪
♪ Bang a gong ♪
♪ Get it on ♪
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-How did you --
-I don't know why. I just --
-That's such a random
song choice,
but also to know the -- like,
you know how some songs
you hear, like, you're not
going to know the band?
Yeah. Alright. T-Rex.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Here, you can go.
You can take this next one.
Come on.
I want you to get this.
-Okay.
Why are you holding on to it?
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. It's -- Okay.
You know what I mean?
This has got to be easy.
You see this?
-I think so.
-Hey, Alexa, name
some cities in Tennessee.
-This might answer
your question.
Nashville, Memphis,
Knoxville, Chattanooga.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on now.
That's how you play the game.
Okay.
Yeah. This should be easy,
right?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Or is it?
Alexa, Hubba Bubba --
Alexa, Hubba Bubba
is a type of what?
-This might answer
your question.
Bubble gum.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
What?!
Dude! That's all she --
That's crazy.
That's all she said.
Dude, I loved
having you on the show.
I don't know. We weren't playing
against each other.
We were playing with each other.
That's my man, Lil Rel Howery.
He's on tour
with Tiffany Haddish.
Go check out some of these dates
right here on the
Best Friends Comedy Tour.
Lil Rel Howery, everybody.
Congratulations
on your engagement, buddy.
You're the best.
We'll be right back, everybody.
Stick around. Come on back.